[Música]
a todos
é eu gosto me apresentar desta forma
porque eu não sou o sinal não sou
estudante eu não sou
não sou aquilo que dizem mais ou menos
que eu sou eu e só que eu faço as
pessoas conquistou sou meu trabalho sou
os meus gostos e acima de tudo sou de
família sou amigos e eu gosto
principalmente falar desta partes os
técnicos de trabalho que é que o gasbol
e aquilo que realmente é e eu quero
fazer mais no dia a dia mas hoje por ser
o que é
falaram também sobre o futuro e
novamente sobre inovação porque nós não
conseguimos pensar em frente será olhar
para o mundo de uma forma diferente sem
pensar nos turistas sem pensarmos a
inovação é tem sido incrível ouvir sem
dúvida alguma que vai bater muito
naquilo que é a minha vida naquilo que é
a gestão do tempo e portanto a partir
daí vocês vão ouvir dizer muitas coisas
já ouviram até agora mas na minha
perspectiva é sempre diferente eu não
sou do cinema no estudo um curso que
exige muito estudo é eu faço é muito
importante a minha minha vida acaba por
ceder por uma série de outras coisas
é eu tenho 20 anos em média é há duas
semanas atrás estava desempregado e
agora as coisas vão mudar outra vez em
cinco anos pense que o designer rui
silva 29 foi uma experiência total daqui
pra frente as formas mais um pouco é e
não só está quieto
vocês vão ver que realmente as coisas
mudam de um dia para o outro eu gosto de
tentar acompanhar essa mudança viver
sempre um pouco na crista da onda e
ficou esperando é quem leva sempre com
um outro objetivo aqui o que eu o quero
falar é sobre o inconformismo e sobre
como isto deve ter um papel importante
na nossa vida mas também na forma como
nós vamos decidir o que vai ser o nosso
próximo passo seja profissional seja
academy seja o que for é quando me
convidaram para vir aqui falar antes de
pôr as coisas em perspectiva porque
realmente eu às vezes não penso em ser
conformista será que é uma coisa que
surgir
israel destaque ao que eu tenho vindo a
forçar ambos a da minha experiência eu
acredito que não eu acredito que
realmente há certos pontos da minha vida
em que o inconformismo foi necessário
para eu poder passar à próxima fase para
poder subir de nível daquilo que é a
minha opinião pessoal acerca da minha
experiência em 2014 foi a primeira vez
que eu senti que fui realmente em
conformista eu tenho há imenso tempo
livre tinha 15 anos
realmente não sei de nada na escola
precisa fazer algum dinheiro
quem é e design importante tentar lançar
a minha primeira marca um mícron micro
firma de design
naquela altura não tinha clientes que
antes fazia deixar de vender meus amigos
mais próximos fiz uns trocos
não fiz nada mais é que deixar isso com
carinho em águas de bacalhau e depois
pensar na próxima fase
a verdade é que isto ficou por aqui
muito inicialmente mas se o fim desde
dessa primeira fase com uma conclusão
trabalhar como propósito realmente
levamos mais nós tivemos um objetivo sem
dúvida alguma que vamos conseguir esse
cara aqui alguns temos proposto
inicialmente e portanto saber o porquê
daquilo que estamos a fazer é mais
importante ainda do que a forma como
estamos a fazer o tudo aquilo que nos
leva a tomar uma decisão saibam porquê
2015 ainda
ainda não está claro portanto juntar em
março são estudantes na altura foi
diretor de campanha do chefe de gabinete
é esta foi mais uma vez uma experiência
importante cima daquilo que tem vindo a
ser o meu percurso é aprender a
trabalhar com pessoas aprende que estava
a trabalhar e trabalhar com pessoas é e
depois percebi que era necessário
coordenar certas partes da minha vida
depois mais à frente e voltaram a abater
a criar aquela frase que você precisa
ter no início e conclusão que eu tinha
aqui é que quanto mais pessoas vocês se
cruzarem muito mais pessoas vocês
trabalharem melhor mas mais difícil é
muito complexo coordenar as nossas
opiniões ter a certeza que a forma como
estamos a lidar com os outros é correta
se as pessoas nos abordam o assunto e
que nós vamos lidar com isso da forma
como estavam que nós lidamos com deus
não queria ter em atenção que quanto
mais cedo melhor mas também trechos dos
vídeos mais à frente
tentei renovar a que o primeiro projeto
tenha criado inicialmente eu fique
o dado era é verdade aqui é a idéia
deste ano disputou muito rapidamente os
meus colegas já não queriam comprar um
jatinho uma porque não sei viver sem ter
uma tia que também precisava de uma
equipa e portanto não há nenhum problema
com experiência que têm vindo a adquirir
até este momento percebi que realmente
era necessário não trabalhar sozinho
trabalhar sempre com outra pessoa que
também possui clima experiência talvez
mais - isso nem fui pro creche irmã
colega no secundário é que elas terão os
clientes que eram seu lado de joaquim na
zona de coimbra malta que também era
jovem piloto conseguiu estar no trabalho
malta como eu sou jovem e certa confusão
nem tudo é o que parece é uma marca não
é um logotipo tanques nem não é na
essência daquilo que nós estamos a fazer
realmente está aquilo que nós vamos
fazer é aquilo que nós entendemos que
deve ser feito
eu escolhi esta fase o vermelho porque
minha formação em design multimédia mas
a verdade é que isto pode ser aplicado a
qualquer uma das duas fases qualquer uma
das duas etapas da nossa vida nem tudo
aquilo que parece isso vocês já sabem
mas também sabem que é no pormenor que
está o resultado está no conjunto das
coisas que está realmente aquilo que
vocês querem fazer em 2016 entra em
design multimédia em entrada também foi
bastante turbulenta o primeiro tinha
matriculado em lisboa depois vem aqui
pra coimbra mas isso é outra história
o que que é isso que estou fazendo
faculdade estas foram algumas das
questões que enviaram a senhora ao longo
dos últimos três anos
a verdade é que o windows não sei estou
dois meses seminário popular
não quero fazer mestrado exatamente
porque estas questões têm vindo a manter
nós como somos quando nos quando nos
enfrentamos o final nem sempre sabemos o
que aconteceu na primeira instância no
primeiro momento senti realmente não era
isso que eu queria sucesso
no entanto ainda em 2007 também
encontrei os nomes nem a empresa deve
ser o que foi
talvez aqui que deu o clique que eu
realmente comecei a perceber porque é
que se vê na faculdade e o que eu estava
aqui fazer neste universo acadêmico pra
mim era tão distante que na minha cabeça
ainda não fazia sentido nós em janeiro a
empresa der certo que nós somos um grupo
ambos têm por objetivo desenvolver
trabalhos enquanto estamos a citar a
honestidade eo nosso usuário no entanto
vemos no objetivo é a recompensa que nós
temos é o resultado do trabalho que nós
vamos desenvolvendo o que dificultaria
coordenar que eu queria fazer com que
outras pessoas tenham fazer o que a
equipa completa queria fazer nós na
altura éramos cerca de 40 pessoas agora
nós temos um caminho mais é também um
papel da comunicação usp também que
trabalhar em equipa nem sempre é tão
simples quanto isso é efeito também qual
é uma importância dos valores da cultura
estamos a trabalhar em conjunto é que só
talvez só um carinho estrangeiro mas a
verdade é que enquanto nossa tecnológica
agora o trabalho sempre um ponto de
vista muito da tecnologia do futuro e
assim que estes aspectos são sempre os
vocais em seja o que for que a vossa
nossa formação e portanto civil incluiu
no texto distante da minha primeira
experiência profissional estágio numa
empresa no mundo real que o gesto no
mundial com clientes reais e possui
também o que queria dizer trabalhar com
suor e quais eram as dificuldades que
cerca a movimentos difícil mas também
algumas dificuldades 2007 a minha
primeira experiência fundar uma empresa
nas primeiras duas primeiras etapas
daquilo que é a formação de uma empresa
entretém com um designer sabe lá eu
queira ser lido qualquer coisa mas a
verdade é que eles confiam em empresas
pappé líquida de cozimento é pois estava
realmente enganados fundamento enganado
sobre tudo aquilo que eu queria fazer
sobretudo que enfrenta até à altura e
portanto decidi que não não era este que
quer fazer mais mas o que é que foi
talvez a primeira em um primeiro momento
em que senti que sozinho neste mundo
absolutamente proibido que vai ser o meu
próximo passo
tive que deixar as coisas andarem a
verdade é que surgiu uma outra
oportunidade de entrar no campo nenhuma
empresa também aqui coimbra é com
projetos substancialmente maior com o
orçamento também o substancialmente
maior
como a carga de trabalho do momento
melhor é e vai entregar muito mais
experiência é ainda mais o desafio de
ser se um dos nossos que
podem compreender o decreto um trabalho
estamos acostumados tão fim da série a
que não estava habituado e poxa sou a
acho que sobre mim
ao mesmo tempo integral nesta nova
profissão
eu tive a oportunidade de viajar pelo
mundo como já disseram tive a
oportunidade de conhecer pessoas nos
estados unidos na tunísia de encontrar
outra malta que se encontra exatamente
nos mesmos objetivos que eu eu fiquei
realmente não estava sozinho percebi que
afinal avião toda uma outra vertente
relacionada com o que eu estava fazendo
com que eu estava vindo a fazer é e que
este conceito de pessoa que estuda mas
ao mesmo tempo trabalho e consegue
manter as suas posições pessoais não é o
único nem as pessoas que eu conheço mas
é algo universal e que acontece com
muito mais pessoas do que o esperado é e
portanto a conclusão é que os cai mais
recentemente foi aí que eu quero
aprender que eu quero conhecer e quer
viajar mas ao mesmo tempo que minhas
ações pessoais não estavam a correr bem
o meu percurso académico também está a
começar a trabalhar o meu trabalho não
se fazia eu não estava contente com
composição em que em que estava e
portanto foi obrigado a refletir sobre
tudo aquilo que tem sido o meu percurso
até agora e tudo aquilo que tinha levado
a tomar as decisões que até o momento
é isso o gráfico representa a minha vida
a minha vida é muito mais importante que
tudo o que era trabalho tudo que era
lado do que propriamente as coisas que
eu não gosto de fazer e portanto também
não é e daqui a dois meses de terminar
popular por tanto tempo similar mas há
uma vontade de chegar ao fim
no entanto não consigo ficar parado como
já vos disse portanto encontrar um novo
emprego
encontrar uma nova forma de conhecer
pessoas e viajar para oxi ver o que é
que todas estas coisas têm com o que o
que dentro desta desde o ecossistema que
fazer várias coisas ao mesmo tempo em
tentar fazê-los vai tentar com os galos
todas bem o que queria
é o que faz sentido isso ser é e
exatamente na construção desta desta
apresentação e depois de ser convidado a
vir aqui contar convosco
eu fui pensar naquilo que são os meus
exemplos e nem aquilo que é o tempo que
eu estava vindo a ser daqui uns anos e
pensar nos filhos pensei no bill gates
movimento que somos muito grandes são
quase os deuses nesta destas casas mas
são os meus objetivos e é para isso que
o óleo como como isso é possível
no entanto estudos têm um plano com o
qual eu não quero apostar que chegarem
academia hangar em a circular num
momento crítico da sua vida em que
realmente esta desposar tanta tanta
tantas oportunidades da escola construir
o conhecimento de outras pessoas e
outros todos os objetivos é importante
porque sei qual é o total se nós
conseguimos cercá lo do shopping se nós
conseguirmos ao mesmo tempo reunir com
com pessoas que se olham pra nós e que
se vê em nós e que partilham connosco os
mesmos objetivos porque nós não podemos
incluir em grupos sem compromisso da
nossa nossa maneira de ser mas incluir
um dos grupos que participam da nossa
opinião que que seja vem na nossa
maneira de ser que gostam de trabalhar
estudar de sair à noite para beber copos
mas que ao mesmo tempo consegue influir
em si a capacidade de fazer todas essas
coisas ao mesmo tempo porque não ser um
quadro stop porque não ser uma pessoa
que para além de tudo o resto faz da sua
vida que tem que fazer porque isso não é
um rei um ser humano porque não estudar
também porque não dará uma oportunidade
na universidade nos acrescentar alguma
coisa enquanto pessoas é é um caminho
que eu queria falar aqui hoje realmente
reconhecer o valor a academia é ter o
objetivo de trabalhar por erros e
conseguir conjugar todos os objetivos
sejam créditos sejam profissionais sejam
pessoais
[Aplausos]